so as we continue our series on how to
kill various superheroes what I want to
do here it's talk about Batman and the
reason why is because I was going
through the comments section of my video
on Franklin Richards which by the way I
had to come through something like 700
comments because YouTube kept
automatically hiding them so if you guys
decide to comment in this video
don't put the word kill because YouTube
will automatically flag it I don't have
to go through for a whole day and try to
filter them all out so if you want to
show up and you want to talk about how
to kill Batman just say how to defeat
Batman it'll make things a whole lot
easier but the reason why I did this is
because a lot of you guys want to know
how to kill Batman like a lot of people
were posting comments like do how to
kill Batman how to kill Batman like I
want to know how you kill Batman now
here's the kicker
unlike Wolverine and Deadpool who have
extremely advanced healing factors or
Franklin Richards who can basically do
anything he wants with his ability to
warp reality Batman is simply a mortal
human being with no special powers
whatsoever and so the issue of how to
kill Batman on its face seems relatively
straightforward since Batman can
literally be killed in any way that any
other human can be killed the problem
with this is that if I read a story
called the death of Bruce Wayne and it
was about how to phase hired a sniper
who shot Bruce Wayne from a rooftop I'd
be pissed and so nobody wants to have
the discussion about shooting Bruce
Wayne with a sniper rifle that's boring
so instead we're gonna try to find a
more creative way a more creative way to
do this so the question is this what
makes Batman so hard to kill well
obviously Batman's a formidable fighter
being highly trained in combat and
various martial arts he's actually an
expert in most of those martial arts
training in about 127 different forms
now this training paired with his peak
physical condition make him one of the
most elite fighters in the entirety of
the DC Universe however there are also a
whole bunch of other characters in DC
Comics who possess superpowers and some
are so vastly powerful that they're well
beyond characters like Superman and so
on now Batman were to go up against
someone like Superman or Martian
Manhunter or doomsday Wonder Woman or
even a plethora of any of these other
characters using only his fighting
skills he's going to be killed super
easily due to their
strength and so we have to turn our
attention to Batman's other attributes
in order to see what makes him so
formidable and probably the greatest
asset to Batman is as almost
inexhaustible wealth now the reason I
say it's Batman's wealth is that it
allows him to develop and acquire all
different forms of technology that make
him a superhero including body armor the
Batmobile the batwing and all the other
gadgets that he uses to fight
supervillains in addition to this he has
an extensive computer system in the
Batcave that allows him to do everything
from access security cameras all around
Gotham to analyzing samples of blood
soil chemicals and basically anything
else he finds what also makes taking
down Batman such a daunting task is not
just his fighting skill and technology
but the fact that he's able to make such
great use of them due to his genius
level intellect it's because of Batman's
intelligence that he's able to be one of
the most efficient detectives in the DC
universe and his intelligence coupled
with his seemingly limitless resources
is the reason that many of his fans
believe that given sufficient time to
prepare Batman could take on any threat
this is basically why you see stuff
Batman with prep vs such and such and to
that end we've seen in comics several
times when Batman has been able to take
down characters that far surpass him and
strength usually by using a superior
intellect and vast resources in the case
of the Justice League story Tower of
Babel which I have two videos on that
you'll find down in the description and
you're welcome to check out the villain
Ra's al Ghul steals a dossier full of
plans at Batman's been keeping on how to
defeat his Justice League teammates
including covering Martian Manhunter and
nanites that will cause him to burst
into flame using Scarecrow's fear toxin
to make Aquaman's scared of water and
using a variation of his own red
kryptonite to neutralize Superman
through immense pain and sensory
overload
now while Batman didn't actually carry
out these plans the fact remains that he
had the knowledge and the resources to
be able to take down an entire team of
superheroes and furthermore this is not
the only time that we see the Batman has
contingencies to take down the league
and issues 35 and 36 a Scott Snyder's
Batman series The Joker is able to take
control of Superman Wonder Woman the
flash and Aquaman by using Joker venom
and sends them to kill Batman now it's
here that batman deploys plan Fenrir or
a protocol that he has in place to take
down the league
as part of this plan Batman dons a
powerful armored bat suit in order to
fight the league and employs other
safeguards that he has in place like
using the blind veils and item created
by the god Hephaestus the Trix Wonder
Woman into thinking she'd already killed
him spraying a frictionless substance in
the Flash's past to send him spiraling
out of control and using a quick-drying
polymer that neutralizes Aquaman now
after the rest of the Justice League is
defeated Superman arrives and Batman
battles him with gloves containing the
shrunken red Suns of dead solar systems
and eventually defeats him by chewing a
gum like polymer laced with kryptonite
and then spitting it in Superman's face
so yeah basically if Batman knows he's
going to have to fight you or really
even thinks the possibility exists that
he may have to fight you he's gonna have
a way to defeat you up his sleeve he's
gonna have a way to defeat you and so
with all that in mind this really
highlights the question how can Batman
be killed but one way essentially is to
take him by surprise and kill him
extremely fast and that threat would
have to kill Batman before he could
retreat to the Batcave and start
formulating a plan to take them down
however the most effective way to kill
Batman is probably to exploit his
altruism and endanger the lives of
innocent people
we see a great example of how this can
be successful in the first issue of Tom
Kings Batman series as part of DC
rebirth in this issue and airplanes been
struck by a missile and Koreans towards
Gotham threatening to cause a
catastrophic number of deaths now again
there's a video on this on my channel
which you can watch in more detail but
basically Batman steers the plane and in
doing this
Batman prepares himself for the
possibility that he won't live through
the crash so with that in mind if you
have a super villain looking to kill
Batman the best approach may not be to
attack him directly since you can either
out fight you or figure out a way to
exploit your weaknesses through
technology but rather to put him in a
situation where he has to choose between
his own life and the lives of innocent
people and as we've seen when those are
the stakes
Batman is willing to sacrifice himself
in order to prevent the death of
innocent people so with that being said
I know this is a pretty short video but
Batman is super hard to kill Batman is
ridiculously hard to kill like you would
think for a normal man for a crazy guy
running around Gotham City dresses a bat
it'd be super easy to kill him but it's
not at least if we if we don't take the
easy road and just say just shoot him in
the head with a sniper rifle from a
rooftop like if we don't do that then it
makes it really hard to kill him because
Batman's defeated basically everyone
like there's never really been a foe
aside from someone who can just wipe out
all existence there's very rarely ever
been a foe where bad you know where
Batman didn't die you know where that
man succeeded in living sometimes other
people helped him but usually it's just
him helping himself so I'm kind of
curious if you guys can come up with
interesting ways to kill Batman that I
haven't listed here post them down in
the comment section because I'm gonna
know what you guys think
cuz this was a tough one this was super
hard and yeah if you guys are new to
this channel make sure you hit the like
button make sure you hit the sub button
to become part of the Rob core and I
will catch you guys later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
you